cnn has been following the sad tale of
dasha kelly uh is a woman whose trials
and tribulations were used as a final
push to get the unconstitutional
eviction moratorium extended she said
that she was a mother of three girls
and facing eviction because
she didn't have a job
and she couldn't pay her pay her rent
now of course
there are millions of open jobs
available right now um but then again
when you're a single mom of three
it may not it's not so simple to take
any job that comes along
you should still be able to find a job
but you may not be able to hop at the
first one because you got to worry about
child care and you've got all these
other considerations of course you have
to take and you have to take into
account
um so so you so you can kind of
understand what a difficult spot this
would be in this would be
uh for a for a single mother with three
young girls to be in this position
so cnn they pushed this story they
followed it
um until finally kelly desha kelly who
put her own gofundme up to raise money
for herself she raised nearly a quarter
of a million dollars which will all go
to her personally
and to her three quote-unquote daughters
so first before we get to the update to
this story the shocking update
here's a couple of clips compiled by the
site now this and they're the ones i
think who added the inspirational music
in the background
um but here is a couple clips this is
cnn profiling kelly and then also later
on getting her reaction after the
gofundme raised all the money let's
watch this
i had to donate a few days ago
kelly is now donating blood plasma 100
bucks a time to buy groceries
so you are managing to eat okay exactly
oh yeah they're
well they're eating okay let's put it
that way i'm like there's days i don't
even want to roll up the
bed roll out the floor
you get what i mean kelly's pawned or
sold nearly everything she had i had a
bed right here there was a tv right here
on top of this dance so i had to pawn
ponder she thought about working online
but you lost your laptop as well oh i
had to pawn that trying to keep over the
bills
i just want to tell everybody thank you
so much i i'm still in denial if you
can't really tell um
it's a lot to take in it's very um
sorry bro
it's um it's really overwhelming these
are tears of joy trust me i'm
uh
i don't i
i'm just so thankful i appreciate each
and every one of you
and i would especially like to think i
don't know if i can but kim the one who
reached out to my family
i'm so thankful i we're so thankful for
you guys because i had no idea what we
were going to do
and just overnight just overnight all
you guys just reached out and helped us
not to support your encouraging words
like
it's it's it's just gave me a lot of
hope and
i just want to make sure i do the best
that i can to help the next person that
is in my same situation and
i just felt really blessed and just
thank you guys so much
you know knowing what we know now
and we'll play what we know in a second
and you and you see those girls sitting
there and they
to me they do look a little bit confused
i mean they're looking up at this woman
and there's there's maybe this is just
me now projecting that back but um
seemed to be a little bit of confusion
and anyway they would be they would be
right to be confused because here's this
woman saying talking about her daughters
and how they you know they live together
in this apartment well
as it turns out
um those girls are not
her daughters she doesn't have any
daughters she's a single woman
and that was revealed by cnn after they
had already raised over 200 thousand
dollars for this woman now we get the
update from that same reporter who was
uh who was doing this story and been
following dasha kelly now he comes back
on cnn
days later and says oh by the way
everything we told you about that was
alive
still a lot of questions um but what do
we know right now about dasha kelly's
story
well erica cnn found desha kelly through
her post on gofundme seeking two
thousand dollars to pay back rent to
avoid eviction for her and quote her
three daughters she did not reach out to
us now we interviewed kelly at her home
the girls all called her mom appeared to
be very much at home and there was
nothing we could see to raise any
suspicion but later last week a woman
named shadia hilo came forward and said
she was the mother of those three girls
and they live with her obviously we
investigated immediately and yes sharia
hilo is their mother we have seen the
birth certificates and
now we know that dasha kelly is dating
the girl's father she spends significant
periods of time caring for the girls at
her apartment now at the time we visited
hilo says she had dropped the girls off
with kelly for a week
now when we followed up with kelly over
the weekend she clarified that she is
not the mother of the three girls she
said she originally described herself to
cnn as a mother because she considers
herself to be like a mother to those
girls
shadia hilo is understandably upset that
someone else claimed to be the mother of
three of her children children she also
cares for
right
well i i said that i was a mother but
you know i i
i hang out with these girls sometimes
and i i consent sort of like a mother i
consider myself though i just didn't
think to tell all you guys that when i
was raising two hundred thousand dollars
you know this this uh and she didn't
involve she at no point volunteered this
information she was gonna take that 200
000 and run
and also by the way the at least at
least the most recent thing i saw last
night anyway
gofundme they're not shutting the
fundraiser down exactly what they did is
they they're requiring deschakelli
to put an update on the gofundme and say
oh hey this was all on false pretenses
i'm not actually a mother these aren't
my girls i lied to you
so she's putting she put and she did she
put that update and now people who
donated to the gofundme those poor saps
who actually fell for this uh they're
gonna get a few days or a few weeks to
claim a refund and then
and then the rest of the money is still
going to go to desha kelly so they
didn't shut it down
now i don't have to remind you
okay
so dasha kelly is allowed to lie
and raise 200 000 and they don't shut
down they still give her a chance
to keep at least some of that money
because not everyone's going to ask for
the refund not everyone's even going to
know that this that this update was was
uh
was posted
um
they're gonna let her do that
meanwhile they wouldn't let me raise
money for a boiler
i was raising money for someone else
i wasn't gonna get a dime of it
and that's an illegitimate fundraiser
and i this is that i don't even see that
say this as a as a joke
okay yeah the abuela fundraiser was
hilarious but at the same time it was a
real fundraiser we were really going to
give the money
to uh to in a boiler in need
here you have someone raising the money
for themselves and lying in the process
and they're going to be allowed to keep
at least some of it i'm guessing a good
chunk of it this is going to remain and
they're going to get to keep it
so obviously this is this is a a scam
this is not oh
i i i misworded it i didn't mean no you
lied
and the actual mother of these girls
didn't know this was happening imagine
you you know you drop your uh
your kids off with someone
and then you and then later you see your
kids on cnn
you see them on cnn starring alongside
person who's babysitting your kids
in this uh in this pageant
so they can raise money can you imagine
that how outrageous and angry
outraged and angry that would make you
so we know actually that descha kelly um
is
so she's not a mom she's not a single
mom
she is in fact unemployed so that much
is true
but that really brings us to and this is
another story i wanted to hit in the
five headlines this is from the daily
wire it says the united states economy
has over 10 million job openings
according to the data from the the
department of labor the number of
positions available in the united states
increased to 10.1 million as of the last
business day in june the highest number
ever observed by the bureau of labor
statistics in may there were 9.2 million
openings there have never been this many
jobs available
um
and
now as i said not everyone
when you have dependents when you have
kids
that complicates matters
clearly if you don't have a job you need
to go find one and you need to keep
hitting the pavement until you do
but you're not going to be in a spot
where you can necessarily just take any
job
because you got to you got to figure out
your child care first if you're paying
for child care then you gotta make
enough from the job to pay for the child
care and also to have some leftover to
pay everything else that you gotta pay
so these are a lot of things you have to
take into account
um
and and
uh obviously we're all very sympathetic
to people that are in that spot but if
you don't have any kids if you don't
have any dependents and you're a single
person
and you're living in an apartment that
isn't you know is that isn't terribly
it's not some luxury apartment in the
sky that cost you thousands of thousand
dollars a month
uh you should just basically take any
job you can find
you take a job and you can keep looking
for a better one while you have that job
bird in hand you know it's easier to
find a job when you have one
you can so you can still do that but
there's no reason to be passing up jobs
when you're a single person
um
that's what i that's what i said from
the beginning about a lot of this stuff
we started handing out
you know we just started handing out
stimulus payments to everyone
now we got the eviction moratorium the
eviction moratorium shouldn't be in
place for anyone because it's
unconstitutional
but if it was if i was going to agree
with it with it being in place for
anyone which i don't but if i did i
would say at a minimum
this should be targeted for i don't know
families
a single person who's choosing not to
work even though there are 10 million
jobs out there
and you have no one to pay for but
yourself
there's no excuse
it's it's not it's it can be very
difficult to support and pay for a
family
i know i do that i support a family of
six
i've also supported just myself i did
that for years
and i was able to do that with not a lot
of money i wasn't getting paid a whole
lot
but as a single person you're an adult
you can make sacrifices you know you can
make it work i did
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content